Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens with migrationology.com,
and I came to Mumbai, India to eat.
In this video I'm going to share with you
ten of the best Indian street foods that you
don't want to miss eating when you're in Mumbai.
So keep watching this video for some incredibly
delicious Mumbai street food.
Starting off at number one is vada pav, which
you’ll also commonly hear as vada pao.
It's one of the ultimate Indian street foods
in Mumbai
that you will find across the entire city.
It begins with a spiced mashed potato mixture,
which is lightly battered and deep fried to a crisp.
The potato patty gets packed into a fluffy
white bun, and then gets doused in a variety
of extremely flavorful chutneys.
I'm not sure if this is a, if you push this
one down and then just kind of pick up the
whole thing, I think you do.
Oh wow.
That is unbelievable.
The real wow factor of this vada pao are the
different chutneys that are involved.
Oh wow.
That's like a salty, minty, spicy, just, powerfully
flavorful, delicious vegetarian sandwich.
Aw, it's really good.
Bhelpuri is the perfect Mumbai beach snack,
it’s crunchy, sour, sweet, salty, and spicy,
and it just makes you want to keep eating
snacking and hanging out.
There are many versions of bhelpuri, but it
often contains puffed rice, sev which are
fried little crispies made from chickepea
flour, stirred up with onions, tomatoes, dhania,
and a balance of salty, sweet, and spicy chutneys.
Once you start eating bhelpuri, you can’t
stop.
For this one I'm going to take the lime and
squeeze it all over.
It's kind of sweet and savory and crispy.
Yah, it's tastes like rice crispies just mixed
with all sorts of sweet and tangy and spicy
and onions.
Oh and there's some potatoes in there on the
bottom there too I think.
Mmmmm.
With that squeeze of lime, that's nice because
it contrasts that sweet tangy sauce.
These little spoons are kind of flimsy.
This is a good beach snack.
Sev puri is a type of Mumbai chaat that happens
to be one of my personal favorites.
A flat crunchy puri is topped with creamy
potatoes and onions, then it’s covered in
tamarind, chili and garlic chutney, sprinkled
with diced bits of sour mango, and finally
it's topped in a heaping handful of sev, which
are thin crispy noodles made from chickpea flour.
If I take out the first one, hopefully we
can all see what is inside.
Oh yah, the cross section.
There are onions in there, and potatoes.
Mmmmmm.
Oh this is one of my favorite chaats.
Mmm.
That potato is so creamy, that it almost reminds
me of guacamole.
It's like avocado almost.
It burns your throat a little bit going down
and then you can taste the sweetness from
the chutney.
It's so well balanced and that is an awesome
snack.
It's like crunchy and juicy.
These are right at that size where they are
almost too big to take a full bite, but then
at the same time you're just not sure if you
want to bite it in half and risk collapsing
the entire, the entire snack bite.
I'll go with the one bite.
Those chutneys, and then everything just collapses
in your mouth.
Pav Bhaji is one of Mumbai’s most dominant
iconic street foods.
It was originally invented in the 1850’s
by street food vendors who took an assortment
of leftover vegetables, mashed them all up
with some butter and spices like cumin and
turmeric, and served it with bread.
Nowadays in Mumbai, pav bhaji is often prepared
on a giant hot griddle, the potatoes, tomatoes,
and spices are mashed up into a puree, swooshed
around with butter and water until they reach
a saucy consistency and it’s served with
a buttered toasted roll to mop it all up.
So it's the combination of pao which is a
bun like this, and the bhaji which is this
tomato potato puree with spices.
You can feel the starchiness of the potato,
but then it has a really nice like tartness
from the tomato.
And then, it's a little bit spicy, you can
taste that like blend of cumin and turmeric
in there as well.
And then yah, you can taste the butter in
there quite well as well.
That's a very buttery fluffy roll.
A really quick intermission, I want to invite you to subscribe to my YouTube channel
For lots more food and travel videos.
Click subscribe now! Ok back to the video.
Grilled meat is an essential street food,
and in Mumbai you’ll find some insanely
tempting delicacies roasted over charcoal.
Along with chicken tikka, seekh kebabs, and
boti kebabs, rolls, which usually consist
of meat wrapped in bread are one of the greatest
on the go, or late night street food snacks.
In Mumbai you have to try the chicken bhuna
rolls.
The rumali roti, a thin circular roti that’s
cooked on what looks like an upside down wok,
is cooked fresh and then stuffed with boneless
chicken in a wonderfully flavorful tomato
based gravy.
Actually I think I should not actually unravel
it, I think you're supposed to tear it, tear
so you don't lose any juices on the bottom.
That bread.
That bread is amazing.
It's really very similar to a tortilla.
Then that's like shredded chicken with kind
of a tomatoey spicy kind of yah, sauce.
That is a comfort roll.
What I am going to attempt to do though, is
add some more sauce and some onions.
And scoop that on there.
Oh yah.
Chai, a tea beverage that’s consumed throughout
India, is one of the greatest street side
drinks.
The black tea is usually brewed strong, mixed
with a generous ratio of creamy full fat milk,
sweetened with plenty of sugar, and it’s
often flavored with cardamom, ginger, or masala
to give it an extra boost.
And it's always piping hot.
Actually like burning hot, my fingers are
on fire right now.
Oh, oh I have missed you.
You can taste just a hint of spice in there,
and maybe a little bit of cardamom in there.
And then it's creamy, it's just fantastic.
Drinking cups of hot tea on the side of the
road is just one of the great joys of being
in India.
Pani puri is an absolute genius of an Indian
street food snack.
Not only is it delicious, but it’s refreshing,
and fun to eat.
A small hole is poked into the top of a puri,
which is a hollow circular chip.
It’s then typically half filled with a combination
of potatoes, chickpeas, onions, and spices.
The puri then get’s dunked into flavored
water to fill the other half of the puri.
You eat them by the single, and you've got
to eat them fast before they go soggy on you.
Mmmmm.
Oh it's amazing.
It just explodes with like juices.
It's salty, it's a little bit spicy.
You can taste like a little bit of like a
minty freshness, and then you have like these
starchy chickpeas in there as well, all wrapped
up by like a hollow chip.
Oh it's good.
And once you finish one bite you get another
one.
Thank you.
Although not always a street food, Bombay
duck is one of the most iconic Mumbai foods,
and it’s something that you don’t want
to miss eating when you visit.
Despite being called duck, it’s not actually
duck at all, but it’s a locally caught lizardfish,
which can be prepared in a number of different
ways, but it's commonly rubbed in semolina
flour, and deep fried.
I got the whole thali, so it comes with a
number of different side dishes, including
rice and chapati, I think these are chapatis.
And then some chutneys and curries.
I'm going to try the bombil fry first.
And you can see these are like little curly
sides of a fish.
I think it's just a fillet side of the fish,
and then it is coated in some kind of coating
and then deep fried.
That is extremely tender.
That just like flakes apart.
Wow that's good.
That is salty and really really crispy.
Ok I'll take that piece of bombil fish, and
mix it in to that rice.
That's amazing.
A sandwich is probably not the first thing
that comes to mind when you think about Indian
food, but when it comes to Mumbai street food,
sandwiches of many different combinations
and styles are very popular.
The basic recipe calls for some layers of
vegetables like masala mashed potatoes, cucumber,
beetroot, red onions, tomatoes, some cheese,
and a few spreads of chutney for that incredible
flavor.
I think the best way to eat a Mumbai street
sandwich is to order it toasted so it gets
crispy on the edges and warm all the way through.
This sandwich was topped with some sev, and
then served with chutney and chili sauce on
the side.
So this is a classic Indian Mumbai street
sandwich.
Oh that is beautiful.
Look at all those layers of vegetables.
And this a vegetarian sandwich as well.
But there is some cheese.
I'm going to take this first wedge of sandwich
and I think I'll go in for some of that chutney.
Oh and I'm losing some ingredients, oh well.
Mmmmm.
I can taste a little bit of cumin in there.
And what I really like is that beet root.
That's really good.
The beet root is just soft and just sort of
dissolves and then you have the crunchy cucumber,
the crisp onion, and then the cheese, just
is melted and just wraps it all together.
And then that like minty kind of chutney in
there as well.
Although dosa is originally from South India,
it’s a street food you’ll find all over
Mumbai as well.
A dosa begins with a fermented batter made
from rice and urad beans that’s swirled
into a circular motion on a hot griddle, and
fried until golden crispy.
A traditional masala dosa is filled with spiced
potatoes and served with sambar and chutney
on the side, but in Mumbai you’ll find some
serious creative and fusion dosas that can
include all sorts of different flavors and
seasonings.
Oh, and it's crispy and soft at the same time.
And go in for all of that beautiful, it's
almost, yah it's kind of like a curry.
But I love how there are so many, so many
greens in there.
I think there's green onions in there as well.
Oh look at that, oh that looks incredible.
Oh wow.
That is incredible.
Wow.
It's just packed full of flavor.
You've got the crispy sort of like spongy
but very thin like almost like crepe like
dosa, and then that curry, I cannot believe
how quickly and how masterfully he whipped
up that paneer tikka.
I was expecting it to be good, but that is
incredible.
And then I will add some extra chutney to
it.
I think this is a coconut, coconut based chutney.
Oh that chutney!
That brings us to the end of this video about
10 of the best Indian street foods in Mumbai
that you have to try.
Thank you very much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed it and that you’re now ready to
start eating.
Thank you again for watching, please remember
to give this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed
it, and leave a comment below, and also make
sure you subscribe for the next videos, and
I will see you on the next travel and food
videos.